On top of the Yonko and the admirals, the one
piece manga just revealed a whole new group of
incredibly powerful fighters called the Holy
Knights, that might end up becoming the most
powerful group of fighters in the entire story
and the final enemies of the straw hats in their
battle against Imu. And you won’t believe all
of the crazy secrets about the identities of
these mysterious fighters that are being set
loose to destroy the world. Plus we finally
learned what happened during the Reverie and we
also see the true powers of the revolutionary
army revealed in a battle so destructive
it could have destroyed an entire island.
But of course we have to start with the holy
knights. Now, this group was actually first
name dropped in chapter 1054, when Akainu
revealed that holy knights are responsible
for resolving disputes in the holy land. But
does that mean they just work for the celestial
dragons? Or can they even hand out justice
to the world nobles themselves? Either way,
they must be pretty damn important – not to
mention super powerful – to become the world
governments ultimate warriors. And
if you’re wondering if they are even
stronger than the admirals, stick around,
because we’ll discuss that in just a moment.
But first in this chapter we get this panel of
the Holy Knights as Dragon says that with the
Holy Knights making their move, the real battle
starts for the Revolutionary army. We learn that
these nine knights they are being sent out to
literally destroy kingdoms that are rebelling from
the World Government. These kingdoms decided to
break off when they found out about what happened
to this kingdom that got destroyed by the insane
light attack [ch 1060]. But the fact that these
kingdoms even know this information makes me
wonder how they learned about the kingdom’s
destruction? Did Sabo leak the information?
Or did the world find out some other way?
Anyway, back to the Holy Knights. These nine
insane fighters are tasked with dealing with
these rebel kingdoms, and we have to assume the
worst here. These kingdoms are probably going to
be wiped out entirely, or at least the rulers will
be killed and replaced. And this gives us some
hint of how strong these knights really are. Since
there are nine knights and eight rebel kingdoms,
I’m wondering if each knight will take out one of
the kingdoms or if they will work as a group and
go one by one. Personally, if these knights are
so powerful I’m pretty sure that they can take out
a normal kingdom on their own. I mean, Sanji’s
brothers basically took out an entire kingdom
with just the help of some clones [ch 828], so
I’d think the Holy Knights have to be at least
that strong. And since Sanji’s brothers were able
to take out some of Big Mom’s strongest children,
that puts these Knights at least on the level of
a Yonko Commander. *Emphasize with some motion*
Again, AT LEAST. And if they are going
to match up with the straw hats later on,
better be at least this strong or they won’t stand
a chance. Because it would be truly disappointing
if Oda introduced 9 unknown powerful characters
this late in the story that then end up like
Kaido’s Tobi Roppo, who, in the end, didn’t
make that much of an impact in the story.
However, could they be EVEN Stronger? since Dragon
seems to see these 9 as the ultimate force of the
world government, there is a pretty good chance
they might be even stronger than the admirals.
Which might make sense, given that many of the
strongest Marines, including even Akainu himself,
don’t like doing the dirty work of the world
nobles. So if many of the marines flipped sides
to join Luffy during the final battle, having
not only the seraphim, but a whole new group of
god-like warriors that fights for Imu and the
world nobles would make a whole lot of sense.
But now let’s put on our tinfoil
hats. Because from the images we
got in this chapter, plus other
clues we can pull from the story,
I think we paint a pretty decent picture of
who these insanely strong knights could be.
Starting obviously with this one right here [show
image of Knight that looks like Shanks], who could
very well be Shanks’ long lost brother or
father. Just the picture alone shows many
striking similarities. Such as a similar body
type, clothes, and even a similar sword. So
unless these knights are shape shifters,
then this guy is probably related to the
Red Haired Emperor. And before you go crazy
in the comments, just remember that Shanks
is actually from the Figarland family which, as
we explain in my complete story of Shanks video,
means that he was most likely a celestial
dragon that got separated from his family. So
what if the Figarland family had another son,
maybe even a twin, who became one of the Holy
Knights. Or another super interesting idea is
what if the Knights are all from the Figarland
family. Kinda like a single overpowered
family who protect the Celestial Dragons.
But wait, there's even more mind-blowing evidence
for this idea, and it comes from chapter 907,
and the famous scene of Shanks meeting with the
Five Elders. So here me out, what if this wasn’t
actually Shanks, but instead it was his
identical brother. And damn this would go
a long way towards explaining one of the
most controversial and mysterious scenes
in the entire story. DO I EVEN NEED TO TELL
YOU how many crazy videos were spawned from
this one scene? Shanks is Evil! The history of
Evil Shanks! Shanks is using Luffy! Honestly,
this scene broke the fanbase and we have
yet to get a real explanation for it. We
never knew how Shanks got in or why the Gorosei
would agree to meet him, but now it is possible
Oda was just toying with us all this time,
because it wasn’t even Shanks but his brother.
I mean, we never actually hear the
Elders call this person by name.
And we never see the scar or missing
arm. And if this was a Holy Knight,
it would make sense that the Gorosei
would agree to meet with them.
But that’s not even the end of the evidence
because in an interview with Japanese TV that my
friend artur from the library of ohara translated
on his website, the author of One Piece was asked
if Shanks is actually two different people. This
was asked with the context that Shanks seems to
be able to move quickly around the world, like
when he stopped Kaido from coming to Marineford
and then shortly after showed up at the war with
his crew. And it seems like Oda-sensei actually
answered the question but it was censored from
the show. So that could mean that this theory is
entirely possible. I mean, if it wasn’t true,
wouldn’t he just have come out and said that?
But with all the incredible speculation about
this Shanks-looking Knight, what about the others?
Well, we can see that one of them wears some sort
of hat, and this one here has horns. So what if
Holy Knights are actually somehow related to the
other Yonko, such as Kaido and Big Mom. I mean,
Kaido certainly has horns. And Big Mom used to
wear a similar looking hat [ch 1041 or other
image of younger big mom]. However, they can’t
all be related like Shanks and his possible twin,
but now I’m wondering if they are clones of strong
pirates. I mean, with everything going on at
Egghead Island, cloning is certainly a possibility
as cloning was even a thing 20 years ago.
But at this point, we’ve thrown out
three Emperor’s as possible members
of these Holy Knights. But now let’s
raise the stakes even higher. What
would you say if I told you that some of
the most legendary figures from the past,
such as Joy Boy himself, were a part of the Holy
Knights. Don’t believe me. Well, keep watching.
So in chapter 906, we first meet this mysterious
cloaked figure, Imu, who we later learn is the
secret ruler of the world. And after they climb
this ridiculously large staircase, they arrive
at some secret chamber that is ice cold. Here we
see the famous image of this frozen straw hat,
which has led to an even greater host of
theories about Joy Boy and this mysterious king.
BUT one possibility that I want to throw out
there is that this freezer is actually where
the Holy Knights live AND that some of them are
the preserved fighters from the ancient past. Now,
there’s a few pieces of evidence to support
this, such as the zombie fighters from
Thriller Bark being frozen to preserve their
bodies. Plus Imu is ascending these massive
stairs, almost like they are ascending into heaven
to reach the Holy Knights. But the most compelling
evidence is this image right here [show image
linked in the research section]. Directly above
the frozen straw hat, is this image of a cross
looking symbol. Now what is this symbol, we
don’t know exactly, but it is very similar to the
World Government’s cross AND a famous symbol of
the Knights Templar [show red Templar cross] which
we will discuss more about in just a few minutes.
But if this is the symbol that represents the
Holy Knights, then that would mean that each
of these little alcoves in this freezer could
be the resting place of one of the knights.
Alright, but that was a lot of wild speculation
from just this small detail – but man it’s just
so much fun and part of the reason
we read one piece in the first place.
But we’re not quite done with the Holy knights
yet, because there are even more connections to
famous characters in the story. For example,
Mihawk could be a former Holy knight. I mean,
he’s always had a heavy Christian religious theme
and the markings on his famous giant sword are
very similar to the markings on Imu’s empty
throne. He has the same ring shaped eyes and
we have no idea what his origin story is or how
he became THE strongest swordsman in One Piece.
The former warlord Barthelomew Kuma is another
character with ties to Christian religion,
since he used to carry around his giant
bible. So was he a holy knight in the
past two? Did he go around smacking the
gospel into enemies of the world government?
There is also the idea that the Holy
Knights could be descendants of Lunarians,
the race that used to live on top of
the grand line and were called gods,
but there’s not much evidence
to support that right now.
But moving on, it's time to throw on your
history hat on top of your theory hat,
because we’re going to do a short de-tour
down everyone’s favorite rabbit hole,
religious symbolism in one piece. And that’s
because the first thing I thought of when
I heard about these Holy Knights, were the
legendary Knights Templar. This is a famous
group of religious warriors who fought for
Christianity in medieval Europe. And there
are a few truly interesting connections
between the Templars and the Holy Knights.
First, the Templars were supposedly
founded by nine original members,
which included warriors as well as monks.
Which makes me wonder if we could see some
non-fighters with the Holy Knights as
well. On top of that, in the bible,
the number 9symbolizes divine completeness or
conveys the meaning of finality. There are also
the obvious similarities between the Templars'
red cross symbol and the World Government’s
cross. So basically what I’m reading into all
of this is that the World Government is really
some massive cult that took over the world. Oh
no, Luffy please save us all. On top of that,
the Templar’s duty was to protect travelers
visiting the holy land, but that is a little
bit twisted in the story because now these Holy
Knights are protecting these so-called “gods”.
But the Templars aren’t the only major symbol
related to these nine Holy Knights. And we
might be able to figure out some more about
these Knights just based on the number nine
itself. First, there are nine Rio Poneglyphs which
supposedly tell the true history of the world,
so could these knights be someone
related to that true history?
Plus, in Japanese culture, nine is sometimes
considered an unlucky number because it contains
the character “ku” which means pain or
suffering. So maybe the Knights are in
constant pain or are meant to protect
the gods from pain. And in the past,
nine was also a number associated with the
Emperor, who was considered divine – basically
a god – so it was considered taboo for
normal people to use the number nine.
And this brings us to Buddhism, which also has
strong ties to the number nine that might tell
us a bit more about the powers or personalities
of the 9 holy knights. For one there are the
9 holy qualities of the buddah: sharing,
ethical morality, patience, renunciation,
wisdom, diligence, truthfulness, determination,
loving-kindness and equanimity. These could be
hints about their characters. Another branch
of the faith has something called the Nine
Consciousness, which are basically nine
states of being and awareness. The first
five states are essentially the five
senses: touch, taste, sight, smell,
and hearing. The sixth state involves your
brain processing these senses into meaningful
information. The Seventh state involves becoming
aware of one’s inner thoughts. The eight state
is sometimes called a storehouse containing
all of a person’s thoughts, words, feelings,
and deeds throughout a lifetime. And this state
is said to persist even after death – Brook’s
matchup anyone? And the ninth, final state,
basically the Buddha state, is when someone rids
themselves of all negative karma and one’s soul
can coexist peacefully with all lifeforms. Whew,
there’s a lot to unpack here, but maybe I’ll
make a future video comparing the straw hats
to each of the nine states to see if we can
figure out who they match up against in a
future battle. So make sure to subscribe to the
channel if you don’t want to miss that video.
But now after spending way too much time breaking
down this new group, let’s discuss everything else
that happened in this chapter and how it will
COMPLETELY CHANGE the One Piece world forever.
So during the flashback to the reverie, we
see Cobra, the king of Alabasta, about to meet
with the five elders. And at this point, we know
that Cobra was assassinated by someone, and that
Luffy’s brother, Sabo was blamed for killing the
king. And before he goes into his meeting, Cobra
tells his guards that they should take care of his
daughter, Vivi. And now why would he say this? The
obvious answer is that he expects to not come out
of the room alive, which is exactly what happens.
But let’s back up a little bit, because I think
the reason that Cobra went to talk to the Elders
in the first place was because government
agents had already captured Vivi. Now why did
they capture Vivi? Well, back in chapter 908,
we see Imu holding a picture of Vivi and then
the Elders asking who Imu would like erased from
history. So basically they want Vivi taken out for
some reason. But back to Cobra, he probably knows
that his daughter has been taken and so he goes
to confront the Elders which of course leads to
his eventual death. However, that is not the end
of all this, because later we see Sabo reacting to
Cobra’s death. This is presumably when the picture
to frame Sabo was taken, but apparently Sabo
was able to rescue Vivi at this point as well.
But I’m also wondering if the Gorosei had another
reason for killing Cobra. I mean, he wasn’t their
original target, so unless it was an accident,
there has to be some other reason they killed
him because killing him would throw the world
into even more chaos. But the only reason I
can think of is that Cobra knows something
about the Void Century, and he threatened
to reveal it unless the World Government freed
Vivi. Remember that the Alabsata kingdom is the
only kingdom that chose to stay on their island
when the other original twenty kingdoms went up
to live on Mary Geoise. Plus Alabasta was guarding
a Poneglyph, so that has to mean they were somehow
related to the Ancient Kingdom. So it makes
sense to me that Cobra would have some other
secret information that the Elders would want
to keep quiet. And I don’t know about you all,
but I am literally as excited as Gojo
[show Manu’s cat] with a new box as
we get closer to finally learning
the secrets of the Void Century.
And this is just another example of the corruption
in the World Government, which is the exact
reason why the Revolutionary Army
has made it their mission to take
down the celestial dragons. And they are
finally moving forward with their plans
because in this chapter we learn that
they declared war by burning the world
government’s flag at Mary Geoise,
just like Luffy did at Enies Lobby.
But unlike my boy Kakashi, these guys are
definitely not sneaky, because there was also
a massive battle between the strongest fighters of
the Revolutionary Army and two marine admirals. We
already knew the flame powers of Sabo, the gravity
powers of Fujitora, and the Forest abilities of
Greenbull, but this chapter revealed more about
one of the most mysterious fruits in the entire
story. This guy is Karasu, who can turn into
a flock of crows. And he uses these crows like
bullets, as he shoots them at Fujitora. We also
got an official name for his fruit, the Susu
Susu no mi, or the Soot fruit. So are these even
crows at all, or are crows just Karasu’s vibe?
The giant okama Morley also shows some
impressive fighting ability when he damaged
Greenbull with his trident. At this point
the revolutionaries are looking pretty good,
but everyone is really tough until the
gravity man whips out his ultimate attack,
which unfortunately we
didn’t get to see the end of.
And while this fight didn’t result in any major
casualties, the whole situation just continues
to pour gas onto the dumpster fire that is the
world government. Because for the first time,
the World Government truly appears to be losing
their grip on the world. Kingdoms are rebelling,
pirates and revolutionaries are declaring war.
They are even going to lose their scientific
genius Dr. Vegapunk. And not one but two
people, Vivi and this guy who I really
hoped to never see again [Wapol] have escaped
with knowledge about what really happened at
the reverie [ch 1074]. And on top of all that,
someone is going to find the One Piece very soon,
which means the World Government’s
secrets are going to be spilled.
But of course they aren’t going to give up
without a fight. And as with any evil world power,
they will surely become desperate to keep their
secrets and power. Who knows, maybe they will
finally unleash their ruthless fleet admiral
to burn the pirate world to the ground. So
if you’re an innocent person living in a world
government kingdom, I would seriously consider
finding a deserted island and hiding until this
epic war is over. Especially because Blackbeard
is closer than ever to finding the One Piece, and
he may have just confirmed that he has the most
broken abilities in the story. And if you want to
find out why, you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching.